all right what's going on guys this is
rob and the trailer for moon night is
coming out later on tonight right it
comes out monday night at the time that
we're recording this video and rumors
abound who it is that ethan hawk is
playing and as i understand it ethan
hawk is actually playing randall spector
although i also have heard rumors that
he's playing uh sun king which i really
hope is not the case anybody who's ever
read moon knight comics is begging
that's not the case but maybe they'll
make him cool i don't know i mean the
concept of sun king was cool the
execution was terribly done but on the
off chance that ethan hawke is actually
playing uh randall spector we're gonna
explain his character here now the thing
about this is that it's not gonna be an
overly lengthy video because there's not
a lot to go on when it comes to the
character of randall spector he's
appeared a few times done a few things
but he was largely marvel's attempt to
try to beef up interest in uh and mark
specter or the very least to kind of
rehash some old story arcs that may
serve a purpose now the thing about this
is that randall first appeared in the
hulk magazine with issue number 17. now
here's something that i do want to
clarify here right a little bit of an
explanation here that's not necessarily
tied to mark spector but it's more to
the hulk but for those of you guys who
are familiar with the incredible hulk
mythos bear with me here those of you
guys who are not of course most of you
guys know the incredible hulk originally
appeared back in the day in a six issue
mini series and he was gray but because
of issues with regards to coloring and
so on and so forth marvel because of the
lack of success as well canceled the
original series and then when they
brought him back he was green the idea
was with the rampaging hulk storyline to
basically fill in the gaps right to say
that like the rampaging hulk stories or
the the comic itself took place between
the original six issue series and then
when he returned in the old tales to
astonish comics the problem with this is
there were a mountain of inconsistencies
here so ultimately marvel just kind of
wrote it all off and just said that it
wasn't really in continuity or anything
some elements were some elements weren't
you can ignore it you'll be fine that
kind of a thing but the idea was that
following rampaging hulk that what
marvel did is they transitioned it into
what was called the hulk magazine and it
was again kind of an attempt to sort of
keep the train of of rampaging hole
going which again people didn't really
care too much about one of the things
marvel tried to do to beef up interest
in the the hulk magazine story was to
actually include backup features
involving like the x-men avengers
different things like that and one of
those was moon knight mark spector and
so what you ended up getting here with
randall's initial appearance is that he
was basically just kind of depicted to
us as a guy at least in the first issues
anyway in issues uh issue number 17. he
was just a guy who was really more akin
to like jack the ripper except instead
of going after prostitutes he was going
after nurses and basically just taking
them out everywhere that he could find
them he would don this kind of mask that
was pretty sick and twisted he would
find them walking the night and then
just take them out and so ultimately
what ended up happening is that mark
spector as jake lockley ended up
basically tracking this guy down now one
of the things to understand we do have a
video on moon night explained um it's
about 12 minutes long not my best work
let me know if you guys want me to like
recreate it right to redo it and
basically do like a more updated version
of moon i'd explain that really brings
into fruition a lot of the stuff that's
going on now but is also more in line
with the normal videos that we do
but when it came to mark spector he
basically had three distinct
personalities four if you consider moon
knight so you had basically mark spector
himself right the mercenary then you had
steve grant who was the billionaire then
you had jake lockley who was the cab
driver and then you had the moon knight
guy who basically just went around and
beat up bad guys in the middle of the
night one of the big things about mark
spector himself about moon knight is
that he actually gets lost in his own
identity that really came to a head in
jeff lemire's run
uh of moon knight where basically he
ended up just struggling with multiple
personality disorder that had actually
been a theme going on for quite some
time and just sort of came to a head in
that story right so it wasn't as though
it was something that was just made up
for the sake of that story but the thing
about this is that jake lockley was
initially the way by which uh mark
spector learned about this right that he
was actually met by crawley which funny
enough crawley is basically just a
homeless guy who exists out there
somewhat of an informant that basically
is one of the many people that tells the
jake lockley persona of mark spector
what's going on on the street level
right thing you know information that he
can't readily get on his own if you look
at the the little tv spot that we got
that featured ethan hawk
he looks more like crawley than anybody
else
to be honest with you guys but i have a
hard time believing that ethan hawk one
of the most celebrated actors in
hollywood is gonna play some random
homeless guy in the moonlight show maybe
he is you know i have no real idea here
but basically crawley ends up telling
mark spector that this guy that's
traveling around out there that this guy
is basically just like killing nurses
but that he has a personal vendetta
against mark spector and marlene and
he's basically trying to track them down
of course marlene being the love
interest of mark spector now because
nobody really knows that mark spector is
actually moon knight at least none of
the people on the street level that moon
knight basically picks this up and says
okay fine like it's obviously some kind
of a personal vendetta but i don't
really know who this guy is right i
don't really know what's going on here
and so what actually ends up going on is
a kind of uh i guess a trap is basically
struck or set up between marlene and
moon knight where marlene will actually
masquerade as a nurse in order to lure
essentially randall out and that when he
goes on the attack that mark spector
will step in right that moon knight will
basically jump in and basically grab
this guy now the kicker about this is
that once the trap is initiated marlene
of course fleeing for her life trying to
escape as mark specter tracks them is
actually met with some overzealous
police officers who end up opening fire
and actually hitting marlene now of
course this basically leads to a fight
between uh moon knight and and randall
right as randall just kind of takes off
and that's where you kind of get the
backstory right that essentially what
had happened here is that randall was a
mercenary working alongside mark spector
but that randall had actually turned
against mark spector just because of the
fact that he found more money by
basically you know turning against the
people he was working with and so
ultimately a fight ensued and then it
was believed that randall was dead and
so ultimately mark spector ended up
basically leaving and became moon knight
after he met with bushmen and all them
and succumbed to his injuries and all
that kind of stuff and so the fight
between the two and this initial story
is a knock down drag out fight like
quite literally these guys are basically
fighting to the death mark spectre
doesn't necessarily want to kill randall
he doesn't want to kill his own brother
but at the end of the day he kind of has
to right now it doesn't really happen by
virtue of him breaking his neck or
anything like that instead randall
lunges at mark spector and mark spector
actually dodges out of the way and that
leads to randall basically being impaled
on a tree and that's it right as far as
this original story went that's all you
got for randall it was one of these
times for those of you guys who aren't
really familiar with comics this is one
of those times where the story arc was
given to us to see whether or not people
would be receptive to it and if they
were then you could potentially see the
return of the character at a future
point in time now the reality is that
interest in this guy at least among moon
knight fans was there people were
intrigued about the idea of mark spector
basically having a brother that nobody
ever knew about and of course people who
had been reading comics at this point in
time in 1978 1979 basically knew that
you could always kind of bring a
character back if you wanted to right i
mean this guy was impaled on the tree
which is by no means certain death right
the guy could recover he could heal and
then basically face off against moon
knight yet again and kind of be this
recurring foe now something that i do
want to talk about here and again this
is something that we'll sort of
reiterate if we end up going back and
doing an actual moon night video i want
to talk about mark spector for a second
and the reason why is because
understanding the return of of randall
specter later on really requires us to
kind of understand some of the stuff
that was going on with mark in between
right so the thing to understand is that
when it comes to the character of moon
knight this guy was basically marvel's
batman i mean it wasn't really something
that was arguable right like when you it
as comics the tone the the philosophies
all that kind of stuff he was by all
standards of measurement batman but more
so than that in terms of the creative
side the writing of the stories how they
were handled all that kind of stuff that
was all doug mink from the time he first
appeared in werewolf by night back in
1975 right issue number 32 going into
marvel spotlight issues 28 and 29 hulk
magazine 11 through 15 17 through 18
issue number 20 marvel preview number 21
like all these things this was all doug
meek the only time that i'm aware of
where doug mink did not handle moon
knight in the early days was with the
old marvel two and one number 52 story
which was actually written by steven
grant and then the defenders issues 47
through 51 which actually had moon
knight basically hanging out with the
team for a little while there was also a
spectacular spider-man story uh really a
couple stories issues 22 through 23 but
by and large moon knight just sort of
circulated around the marvel landscape
not really being tied down to anything
in particular until you really got
around to west coast avengers and then
around that same time he got his own
solo series now the reason why i bring
this up and mention this is because with
doug mink being the guy who spearheaded
marvel doug mink ended up leaving marvel
comics so there were some disagreements
going on behind the scenes between mink
and jim shooter as there were with a lot
of people in jim shooter but doug meek
actually ended up leaving to go write
for dc comics where he basically wrote
batman and detective comics and so in an
effort to try to find a way to rework
moon knight to make it more popular for
modern audiences as they'd been at the
time marvel basically ended up launching
a mini series that was referred to as
moon knight fist of const that was
designed to kind of rework the character
and this is also one of those things one
of those stories uh really going into
the next volume that dealt a lot with
the idea of him having multiple
personality disorder now one of the
things that was hit on in the early days
is that he might have actually been
schizophrenic but that's also one of
those misinterpretations where
schizophrenia and multiple personality
disorder are perceived as being the same
thing they're not right schizophrenia is
just the inability to distinguish
reality from fantasy multiple
personality disorder is literally having
multiple personalities but that's where
that early depiction began to come from
with mark spector basically being unable
to differentiate whether or not his real
identity was jake lockley or steve grant
or mark spector or even moon knight
right like it was it was difficult for
him to be able to tell the difference
but regardless with doug mink leaving
the series and then basically moon
knight getting his fists of concho mini
series essentially the writing duties
failed to chuck dixon now chuck dixon
wrote it for about 24 issues and then
effectively bailed without really
finishing any of the storylines that he
had and so what you got were just a
series of successive writers that were
trying to wrap up existing storylines
and then also trying to basically
you know bring back what readers they
could because people were just dropping
the series left and right and that's why
you ended up seeing the return of
randall because seeing randall return
was basically a lot of old school fans
seeing the series returning to what made
it great in the first place right like
the old doug mink days and so with terry
cavanaugh being the writer at the time
what you got was the blood brothers saga
and this was actually more of a team up
story between the punisher and mark
spector than anything else and so the
idea behind this is that sort of
following the tracks of like the old
dunk being stories what terry cavanaugh
did was quite literally have marlene
attacked by a guy and then immediately
within like the first pages of it
happening that it basically turned out
to be randall right that randall had
somehow returned and it was one of those
funny things because with randall having
been gone for so long terry cavanaugh
seemingly just kind of picked up right
where they left off right that as soon
as mark spector realizes that it was
randall that it attacked marlene that
the mask had basically been left behind
when marlene had pulled it off that he
realized it was the mass of randall and
it's quite literally a flashback to the
old dugming story back in the old hulk
magazine and so from there it's quite
literally uh moon knight just sort of
tracking down randall everywhere he
possibly can and trying to find a way to
defeat him at the same time you also had
the punisher who was hot on the trail of
what were basically advanced idea
mechanics weapons that were being
brought in through a weapon shipment in
the city of new york and so all this
traced back basically to a woman by the
name of neptus now the whole idea behind
this and it was one of those things that
was somewhat interesting so depending on
who you talk to some people will love it
and some people will hate it that over
the course of those conflicts anyway
punisher and mark specter working
together and so on and so forth what you
ended up finding out is that randall and
nephthys were basically lovers at one
point in time when randall was a
mercenary of course nephes was as well
but what you ended up finding out is
that somewhere along the line randall
had been injured and it actually
witnessed mark spector being brought
before the statue of the egyptian god
contu and basically being resurrected
and that randall wanted that exact same
kind of power of course himself being
injured approaching the statue praying
to it hoping for some kind of
enhancement and ultimately not getting
it but he also stumbled across a kind of
prophecy of sorts that basically said
that like somebody was destined to
replace mark specter as like the new
moon knight right to basically you know
be the the new fist of konshu and the
idea is that it would be randall and so
what they did is they essentially took a
person and then brainwashed them use a
series of chemical modifications and so
on and essentially duped that person
into believing they were actually
randall and so when mark spector and
randall initially fought in the old
school hulk magazine comics that was not
actually randall instead it was just a
great big huge ruse all leading to this
moment and the idea was to essentially
use a combination of technology and
magic to enhance randall himself and
actually give him a host of different
powers which he got right he got like
bulletproof skin and he had enhanced
strength and durability and so on and so
forth and so it ultimately all just kind
of came down to like a battle to the
death between himself and mark which as
you would expect ultimately saw more
coming out on top now the funny thing
about this is that it was not actually
mark who defeated randall it was
actually the punisher who defeated
randall now the way that worked is that
with randall having like bulletproof
skin terry cavanaugh had to kind of find
a way to work around this rod almost
sort of wrote himself into a corner what
you basically ended up getting was just
the punisher's knowledge on how to
overcome different people who were out
there and so he literally ended up
shooting randall to pieces right just
like shot this guy up with randall
having what was in effect bulletproof
skin he was very similar to luke cage in
fact he was identical to luke cage in
terms of how his powers worked his skin
was bulletproof but his internal organs
were still pretty you know they were
just your standard internal organs and
so when he was ultimately knocked out of
a building by the punisher he ended up
just kind of crash landing to the ground
which basically shattered his body and
that was it right he was it was just
essentially believed this guy was
basically dead and so following this
randall didn't reappear for years in
fact it was something like 10 years in
fact i think it was a little longer than
that it was about 16 years he didn't
show back up again until 2010 with the
shadowland event now i loved shadowland
i thought it was a great story the moon
knight tie-in was kind of dumb
um i don't know exactly why marvel
decided to bring randall back after all
this time it wasn't as though randall
was one of those plot threads that fans
had just kind of been clamoring for they
wanted to see him return or something
like that i mean the run of moon knight
right the mark specter moon knight
series vol 3. that ended with issue
number 60. and moon i just sort of
free-floated around marvel for a little
while until he eventually got his own
solo series again which was cancelled
shortly after it was launched but the
daredevil shadowland event was a
phenomenal story because what it
actually dealt with was basically uh
matt murdock being possessed by the
beast of the hand right those of you
guys who don't know what the hand is
it's the mystical ninja organization
based out of japan it was basically a
unification that was brought together by
kaganobu yoshioka like way back in the
day and then once they started
worshipping the beast that's when they
started gaining like the mystical
abilities to resurrect the dead right so
the hand only ever operates in one of
two ways either they'll send like a
single assassin to take you out or
they'll just send like 500 of them right
like you'll literally just be like a
hundred ninjas all just descending on
you that's usually what they do when
like wolverine fights the hand because
of his healing factor and his ferocity
his berserker rage and all that kind of
stuff they just send a ton of mystical
ninjas after him but daredevil had
basically been possessed by the beast
and then he ended up turning hell's
kitchen into what was called shadow land
when he effectively created a kind of
empire for himself now at the end of the
story of course danny ran the iron fist
ended up like freeing him from
possession of the beast and then matt
murdock killed himself and then was
immediately resurrected by elektra and
just it was it was a cool story it had
some wonky moments here and there but as
far as moon night goes essentially what
had happened is the return of randall
was never clearly fleshed out basically
he actually ended up surviving and that
he was basically being brought before
the hand to kind of work for them in
order to take out moon knight and then
replace him to basically become an agent
of the hand of course daredevil
operating under the assumption that like
he would not be defeated which is of
course how most villains end up
operating and so what you got in that
story was something that was very much
akin to the old maximum carnage
storyline right where carnage showed up
and then he basically would like kill
people and then write like maximum
carnage or like carnage rules like he
would write that kind of stuff in blood
that when randall showed up much like
his previous iterations he was
essentially insane and so he immediately
started killing a whole ton of people to
draw the attention of mark spector and
when mark spector didn't catch up to him
fast enough he attacked marlene now
marlene didn't die but good lord this
girl couldn't catch a break she ended up
having a miscarriage as a result of the
attack but this level of ferocity ended
up sending mark spector into overdrive
who basically ended up tracking down
miranda to the city of new orleans now
this conflict actually spanned a variety
of different locations but where mark
spector was chasing randall randall was
chasing what was called the crescent of
the moon now the whole idea behind the
crest of the moon is that it was the
only known artifact that could actually
kill the beast and so it was really more
of a mission that was assigned to
randall by daredevil in order to ensure
daredevil's continued reign while being
possessed by the beast but the fight
between the two got pretty extreme all
the way to the point that when randall
was pushed to the place where he was
effectively going to lose kind of
revealing his identity to mark spector
yet again he strapped a bomb to himself
with the intention of blowing everybody
up and then of course mark spector ended
up killing him with the crescent because
of the fact that randall had bulletproof
skin the crescent was the only way to
really kill him and that was the end of
randall the reality is we haven't seen
him since whether or not we will is
anybody's guess there's no reason to
believe we will he was never a
significant character he was a character
that marvel has kind of brought back
every so often in an effort to try to
tell fans hey like we're going back to
the doug mink days and then by the time
he returned during shadow land nobody
really cared because most people who
were reading comics at the time didn't
even know who he was he was just a
random guy that turned out to be the
brother of mark spector so the
significance of the history between the
two was largely lost on them that
combined with the handling of the story
was okay but it just didn't really
resonate with readers at the time and so
the results of this is that marvel never
really had a reason to bring him back
more recently in marvel comics those of
you guys who are curious and we're
actually covering it here on the channel
and the mark spector stories in the
moonlight stories what you actually have
what's going on right now anyway
something called the midnight mission
where he's basically like running his
own thing and you know doing his kind of
you know saving people at night who need
it and people can come and ask her ask
for help and different things like that
but you've actually got what's called
the left hand of conscious the other
fist of country basically a person who's
kind of like the antithesis to moon
knight how that will play out as
anybody's guess but i would say that
with regards to ethan hawk and we'll
talk more about this on geek culture
explain with regards to ethan hawk he's
probably a combination of the two right
that is basically a kind of continuation
of the story of what if randall had
actually gotten the power of moon knight
in addition to mark spector himself
right the blessing of konshu and he's
basically a combination of like the
current other fists of konshu with the
history of randall specter so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace